good morning everyone um thank you for
joining and staying around I appreciate
that my name is Manuel Lloyd hopefully
today I'll be able to help you find ways
to identify means to help fight a
cyberattack specifically a ransomware
attack and if you don't already have
ITIL knowledge of IT service continuity
management people call it business
continuity this is the best way to fight
against our in somewhere attack and
hopefully i can give you a suit starter
to go ahead and get going on this all
right so if you can't see my screen just
please let me know but the first slide
should say ITIL Service continuity
management versus or anywhere all right
so let's go to the next slide um talk a
little bit about me you know I've been
in this industry for quite some time now
about almost 30 years and ransomware has
been one of the worst attacks I've ever
seen in cyber space and it seems that
the only way to defeat it at the point
is to make sure you have good backups a
good disaster recovery plan emergency
mode operations application criticality
things of that nature maybe we can get
into the whole business continuity model
what am I going to try to do that today
I'm just give you a few slides to just
try to make this really easy for you to
get started I know simply learn has a
very good ITIL training sort of sort of
certification training so definitely
look into their certification training I
can just tell you personally that I got
ITIL certified back in two thousand and
four or five or six or something like
that because I saw that this was the way
of the future for IT and anything
involved a business whether it be
healthcare backing retail hey sector is
going to need a fast lean accurate
and hassle-free type of framework as I
chill so definitely look to get ITIL
certified okay so let's get right into
it the problem is that most businesses
are ill-equipped to quickly respond to
ransom they just they just can't do it
ransomware moves very rapidly because
it's based on the files it locked on all
the files and you know how how fast how
fast that can move so it's a huge
problem right now read somewhere and the
health care industry i know i just did
another speech about health care is
about eighty eight percent of the
attacks and read somewhere right now
which means your your health care
information is easily exposed and a
problem is that these health care
relationship and one of the biggest
things I've seen is that the ransom is
only at times about five hundred dollars
i mean do you really think if someone
has you that tied down to all your data
they only want five hundred dollars
there's something to this and it's going
to be a ever increasing problem that's
just going to grow even more over the
next five years in my opinion you know
wrestling where as a global friend you
know you look here i got this from avg
you know this is this shift that I
believe in its you know Germany is hit
the hardest in United States Italy
Netherlands it's all over the world is
it again it's all over the world because
we have a very very weak internet system
you know that's another soap box top
topic for me is that our internet system
it's just asinine and just antiquated
and it meets a change seriously needs a
different kind of gated type of internet
I'm actually having a vision I'm working
on this patent pending right now trying
to help y'all do my part and making a
better internet so it's a global problem
what's the solution you can pay the
ransom you could try to find it you can
try to decrypt the data you draw a whole
bunch of things most people that hermana
they paid a ransom so we can get our
it back but you have to understand if a
guy or gal who's our rent somewhere
someone who's putting ransom I on your
network they're not net want to give you
your data back but you don't have that
guarantee just like a real ransom you
know you watch the movies you see real
ransom situations where people say
they're going to do this and that if you
do this and that they never do it and
you just have to be careful so the best
thing to do is stand up and fight this
bully it's a bully and the best thing to
do with a bully is to stand up to it not
run away from it so the biggest way that
you can fight ransomware attacks is
number one you want to start with your
perimeter defense right in the car
access and distribution layers you know
all your infrastructure are in
connectivity your mobility any kind of
performance issues that you see in all
these in and you want to you know try to
take take a look at those and then
course your business continuity and
disaster recovery your security in cyber
security but at the end of the day it's
going to be a good backup and disaster
recovery plan that's what's going to
help save your tell an arrest summary
tab so let's start with how you get
involved with IT service can a
continuity management the first thing
you have to do is initiate something you
have to initiate this whole process
right so you have the draft policy you
have to get the scope allocate resources
and you have to agree on the project and
quality plans this is huge I mean this
is this is the preparatory piece of this
and so many people who are in IT
departments get pushed to make things
happen just flip a switch right and no
actual come on and it's just as simple
as that right well as a 19 manager
director of V Meath paci oh you have to
stand your ground you have to run you
have to stand your ground when it comes
to especially protecting company
critical data and say look this is not
just flicking on the lights we have to
really deep dive into this thing to make
sure we're doing it right and the
preparation piece of it is drafting a
policy
on what are you going to do you know
there's several things in a business
continuity continuity plan you know you
and we'll go through the those real
quickly they may not get ahead of myself
so drafting a policy right I'm sure you
go out to get some boilerplate templates
out on the internet or whatever the case
may be but you know um make sure you
have a quality a qualified person who
can help you draft a real IT service
continuity management plan and you can
learn yourself if you if you take some
of simply orange courses I've gone
through them myself and I was already
certified but I've just gone through
them and they're very very good or
excellent wish i would have had those
when i got certified several years then
you have to build a scope you have to
think about what you're dead a framework
like you know do you have disparate
silos of data do you have one huge
database or one main database do you
have one location that you have multiple
locations there's so many things that
you have to draw to apolog-- map and met
out what you're going to do in your
policy for your IT service continuity
management they have allocate resources
you know I was working with a large
hospital and they asked me to say hey
look you know we want to do this this
this and this and that that's well how
many IT people you had they said we have
this video that's not going to be enough
you're going to need more people than
that and so the the the the chief
officer at the time and said write to me
without even hesitation i'm not going to
add any more people tonight each that
they should be a headless themselves
that's not a reality you have to think
about your data as money we have to
think about your data has money and if
you you know how we treat money your
data is money really at the end of the
day it's money because when your data
Stan can operate you're losing money
losing employers you're losing
reputation with customers patients the
whole nine yards and they have to agree
on the project and quality plants you
know what are you going to do to make
sure that this works let's go to the
next up so the first thing you have to
do
is a business impact analysis and what
is a business impact analysis well first
of all you're going to be able to
identify all your critical business
functions right so I but I use it for
that where you go in create a pattern of
operational efficiency right so it's a
XY axis where you take the horizontal um
platform which is IT and you take the
verticals which are different business
functions and departments that you align
them together to be able to get this
business impact analysis you want to be
able to identify the essential aspects
of the critical business functions
including all the dependencies
information infrastructure support
facilities key personnel technologies
you know everything the facilities
everything you don't want to miss out
anything because most things are tied to
information technology these days excuse
me also in the business impact analysis
you're going to be able to assess the
likelihood of destruction of the
business in the event of a loss you know
each of these elements of various
periods of time so this is where you get
into the maximum tolerant tolerable
outage to MTO and then the RPO and then
the RTO you know the RPO vendor recovery
point objective the art p 0 RR t 0 being
recovery time check you have to sit down
with with your staff and routine and
come up with how long can we meet now
you know at what point can we want to
recover from and what time do we want to
recover our data and then finally in the
business impact analysis you want to
assess the cost of the disruption and
the effect on the business and the
recovery time scale for each business
unit so the cost is important so you
have to go to your chief operating
officer or chief finance officer say hey
look and we were down as an entire
organization how much does that cost us
per hour okay is it a hundred thousand
dollars and ours is it a half a million
dollars an hour or if there's certain
departments that are down what does that
cost us per hour so your business impact
analysis is going to be able to get you
to that point to understand this and
this is a four
you can download from any places um you
know I have forms if anybody wants to
reach out me to try to help you with
that but you can get a form that
actually asked these questions to get
you a good picture of your business
impact ah the next thing you want to do
is a risk assessment and I till they use
a cram a method you know and that's a
very very long acronym and I'll get it
to you in moma but you know step one in
this risk assessment is you want to
identify the physical threats of
ransomware disruption to the business
what are the physical threats to ransom
work well in an ITIL um IT service
continuity management model it's going
to the principles they are going to help
you identify these physical threats and
be able to put them down on paper and
come out at the end of the day with a
business continuity management plan that
you can present to your entire
organization all the c-level executives
all the middle managers and junior
managers and even a board of directors
so that you have a plan the second step
is you want to evaluate and measure the
measures in place to reduce the risk or
the impact of the ransomware and a third
step you want to implement on and by the
way everything I'm giving you right now
comes directly out of the ITIL training
everything I'm giving you is nothing I
made up this is directly from ITIL
training that will help you be able to
identify this I've only shorten it
because there's not enough time for me
to go through an entire IT service
continuity management plan but these are
some of the main bullet points here um
the third step is you want to implement
any measures that should be taken to
reduce the risk or the impact of
ransomware the next step is a strategy
you know what strategy are you going to
use you got to determine a minimum
resources required a continuous central
operations in each critical business
area in the event of a ransomware attack
some of you on this call you know you
have tens of thousand employees in your
organization so I may have just you know
25 get over it doesn't matter ransomware
moves at the speed of the of your
network so you have a 10 100 1
network is going to go ahead a gigabit
per second to spread itself all over
your network another matter if you have
10,000 employees doesn't matter you have
25 what doesnt matter its to cost okay
so if you have 10,000 employees often
it's going to cost you more and recover
from that maybe if you have 25 applause
you want to review the effectiveness of
your existing continuity arrangements if
you have any at all and I'll get into
those different types of arrangements
that you can have in a moment here you
want to be able to identify and evaluate
alternative recovery strategies you want
to select the appropriate strategy and
then you want to determine the
availability and location of all
alternate supplies equipment resources
yadda yadda yadda right so this is the
next thing that you want to be able to
do let me go back here for a minute tell
you what this this this cram is here
this is the compute of central computer
and telecommunications agency risk and
management model it's a long a long
acronym but you can look that up but at
central computer and telecommunications
agency risk and manage and method and
management models let me say that one
more time central computer and
telecommunications HC risk and
management method okay I said model but
I met method alright so let's go to the
next slide here is you want to get your
organization straight you know typically
you have a board of the rector
stakeholders or I mean I'm sorry
stockholders shareholders they're the
ones the reason why they are in this
become during a ransomware attack
especially in health care there's a lot
of publicity that goes on any ransomware
attacks is going to carry some publicity
to it and as you've negative especially
if you're providing a service to the
mass market so the board of directors
are going on want to worry about their
reputation and and of course costs costs
are for everyone even now to the IT
worker because if you can't recover from
a ransomware attack and or if you
allowed it to happen you couldn't lose
your job not because you did something
wrong but because the company is not
going to be in a sustained keeping on
staff they can't provide services but
the board level there there
possibly with crisis management
corporate decisions and external affairs
public relations you know all this goes
into a business continuity plan built
upon ITIL IT service management model so
that's why it's so important that if you
don't know and you just can't go read a
book by the way you know trying to read
a book through this because the IT
service continuity model ties into all
the other disciplines of ITIL so I
highly suggest that you get trained and
of course this is simply learning we're
on their platform today they really have
a very very good platform of money from
anywhere from any device which is really
cool then your senior management very
responsible for coordination direction
arbitration arbitration resource always
the authorization that's going to be all
your sea levels and then your director
levels are going to be you know the
junior management for education team
leadership site management liaison
reporting linear your middle near your
supervisors your IT managers and things
of that nature task execution team
membership is and this this is important
because when you're building an IT
service continuity management plan you
have a list of the members in your plan
and what they're all to do and it's like
a crack at this window in case of an
emergency situation right so you break
the window and you pull out this plan
and you have this plan and you only have
one drop of this playing final draft of
this plan somewhere at a safe that it's
the official plan so you don't have a
real plan out there that doesn't have
anything to do with your organization
the next thing you want to look at an IT
service continuity model is your standby
wrench you know the standby arrangement
basically is what are you going to do
when you get into a situation of
wrestler you know you don't do anything
which is rarely used obviously you're
going to try to a manual work around you
know this is interim I don't recommend
it you have reciprocal arrangement wait
to say look we are business a down the
street is a immutable business to what
we do and they have better facilities in
us or we're telling them hey if our
building goes down
we could we could put put your stuff in
our data center fire stuff goes down can
we put our stuff in your data center so
you have a reciprocal arrangement then
you have an immediate recovery you know
that's the most desire is also the most
expensive you know then you have the
gradual of recovery anywhere from twenty
four to forty seventy two hours and that
goes back to what I was talking about
getting what your senior financial
people say well how much money does it
cost for us to be down per hour this is
where this started started coming on
which actual arrangement you decide to
go with the dormant of contract
typically is you have a place that says
okay we're going to have a place then
we're going to have our backup stuff and
we're going to call that places hail if
we're in a disaster turn up our
environment force that can take about 72
hours that's really risky too because
when you think about it 72 hours and if
you're making a million dollars an hour
in your organization you know you talk
about 72 million dollars before you even
get a chance to even start to recover
that's just simply not going to work for
most an average downtown for ransom it's
about two days so that's a lot of time
you know that's that's 16 hours in a
business day you know that's 16 million
dollars that's a lot of money then the
last thing you need to have them that
wraps around all of this it's thought of
insurance I recently did a a webinar a
lunch and learn with a company called
med mal direct med mal direct provides
cyber insurance and I've work with a lot
of help on a lot of the insurance
companies but they have a very good
program so if you don't have cyber
insurance find somebody I mean I don't
know what how far med mal directs go
they may just be in North Carolina but
you know but it's m.ed nal direct and
they sell malpractice insurance but
that's not really my concern my concern
is the cyber insurance but check with
your local insurance carrier make sure
that you have cyber insurance in place
well you're going to be Sol and up the
river without a paddle as they say they
want to talk about your recovery plans
your recovery plans is you know you want
to be able to prepare
the detailed procedures and task
required to affect the strategy that you
selected you know going back to the
strategies again right now with strategy
stand by a strategy that you select ok
you want to sign the responsibility for
carrying out the procedures and tasks to
ensure the plan and individual
responsibilities are known and
understood by everybody that that is
involved and you have different teams
crisis management team facilities team
recovery team you know technical teams
senior management team all these
different teams come together to try to
help me recover it's not just the IT
people who are doing this this is a job
for everybody in the organization and it
starts with good training by the way
making sure people don't click on these
stupid little phishing schemes to think
of that nature and then the last thing
here is ensure that the plan is captured
in a form that can be maintained easily
retrieve and easy a readily updated when
you put together nike service continuity
management plan it should be constantly
updated on a major change and even on
the minor changes and you need to put
that information in the plan now um I
don't have I don't think well I could
i'll check with simpler but i can send
you a separate plan that you can work
with if you send me a note here that you
can put together but again trying to do
this without any kind of training you'll
be more dangerous than you are health so
just be careful with that you want to
talk about risk reduction in IT service
continuity management you know what are
your countermeasures you know are you
going to use a fortress approach now
fortress approach is good in the sense
that you're solid you're not going to
get in trouble you do a lot of things
that basically it's like a bunk problem
is though is that if you do a fortress
approach then you could also run into
the risk of not being able to get
recovered any time typically a force
approach is for people who are trying to
protect their data and they don't really
have any customers that they need to do
service to on a daily basis like
hospital so they want to make sure that
that they're there let's look like a
banquet application maybe because you
know you have a tea and stuff so you
have to be really careful with that
there's more information on IT service
continuity management about a fortress
approach in the training from sibling I
believe let's see let's go to the next
slide here we start a little late so I'm
trying to get through this and might be
mindful everybody's time so the
operational activities that you have
here are going to be a education like I
said before you have to educate people
you have to train them test test test
test and then test again I I cannot
stress enough the importance of testing
and IT service continuity management
plan I just cannot stress that enough
that testing will save your tail every
single time and change men is a change
in management is important piece of the
pie excuse me because anytime you change
anything in your environment it's going
to affect the way the entire environment
rules you have to as an IT person relate
to your senior leadership that I t is
not just some utility it is a part of
the business strategy is it is a major
part if you're an IT and you don't have
a seat at the board or see that the
senior level you need to be there even
if you're just IT engineer someone needs
to be there tune up to make the board
members and that senior level numbers
mindful of the fact that I t is a
critical part of the decision-making
process when it comes to dealing with
the data then you want to review your
document over and over again so this is
a cycle educate train test change matter
review education change our training
testing change management review so
virtually every business will experience
some type of downtime these are some
statistics that I got here and virtually
every business pervasiveness of downtown
91 % of those survey have had a data out
center outage in the past 24 months and
if you're on this call here you could
probably relate to that because some
because downtime is not
common thing now forty-seven percent of
companies experienced knowledge or
downtime this year lolly 2016 here the
top cause of the downtown most people
think it's natural disasters but when
you look at natural disasters here you
know you see that it's only 5% and
that's what most senior manager thing
well you know we're not going to have
worried about hurricane or storm no it
could be electronic failure and now read
somewhere is this this is older data but
because recently a security group came
out there ransomware has superseded him
Adair you know human air is twenty-two
percent but electronic hardware failure
is a huge part of it you know but
ransomware and I should have had this in
here and I don't but read over here by
the human error ransomware it somewhere
and it in between hardware and human
error no downtime can be expensive like
I told you before you want to go to the
one of the number one question is 19
litre or 19 engineer a CIO VP technology
you want to ask your CFO or your seal or
whoever controls the burn the cash burn
of your company how much money does it
cost us to be down per hour that
information is going to be huge for you
because when you're putting together
your disaster recovery plan you need to
know the MTO RPO and RTO the maximum
tolerable ilyitch time the recovery
point objective and the recovery time
objective this information is huge and
making your plan makes sense to your
senior management because when you put a
dollar amount on it it doesn't become I
teen anymore it becomes a part of the
business which should be in the first
place but sometimes you have to do
dollars you know I have clients right
now that lose millions of dollars per
hour as much as little as then you lose
five thousand dollars either way to them
the economies of scale is huge for them
when they lose any money because of
something silly or ignorant like a
wrestler attack excuse me you know
but there's a lot of barriers to being
able to do something to feel over your
data to get it back up to get it back
right there's a lot of barriers today
let's talk about those are real quick
you know you'd be too expensive or you
don't have enough people to help you get
things back up and going that's
typically the case you have an IT person
an overworked underpaid undervalued in
many cases they just can't do that damn
job you know so it's hard for them to be
able to get their job done and these
statistics by the way come from actual
tech media just to give them credit them
mystics from but they can't do their
jobs and and twenty percent others
compatibility and complex issues
interoperability is a huge problem in
many audience industries and it has been
and it will be for quite a while until
somebody comes up when the easier way to
do it or an easier way to stop you know
playoffs lessons unfortunately so then
how do you get through these barriers
well here are your trade offs you can
you can try to have an off-site tape
backup and in my opinion you know maybe
many of yours takes all the worst thing
you can actually do their 100 reset
failure in my opinion can you imagine
Lord organization trying to do a restore
from tape how long that would take going
back to the dollars per hour that you
lose right how much down time are you
down per hour that's all the board
members and the sea level people are
going to care about how much money I we
lose then you have cloud backup a lot of
people are doing that you know that's a
great option but then you get into your
bandwidth issues you have the increase
your pipe of your bandwidth because you
don't have enough your daily change rate
is so huge that if you don't get through
a whole back up cycle your backup
windows just don't work right then you
have an appliance on-premise where you
can say okay back up to this planet
fitting that plants can back up off-site
that's a great option you know then you
have a cold side dr cosine new yards one
of those options where your strategies
we can say okay i have a cold site and
i'm going to do
they are there that still takes up to 72
hours you have a warm site that's going
to be put you have 14 hours or 48 hours
and you have a hot side which is the
most expensive it you can have you can
be back up within 12 to 24 hours in most
cases right but then you want to get to
dr AAS Nirvana disaster recovery as a
service this is what is a huge thing and
I think that IPO is probably going to
include this this is my opinion it's
probably gonna include dress as part of
its framework in his next iteration all
right so you want to get that this dr as
a service has all of this you have on
prem appliance all your servers and your
dad has been back up to that and it goes
to the cloud and you have d yep disaster
recovery Nevada okay now what I'm going
to talk about is I've looked at a lot of
companies that do this so many of you
are saying I want to be certified many
and I till I want to be able to know
that ITIL cert IT service continuity
management but I have a situation i have
to deal with right now and i'm going to
give you some resources for that in a
moment here but but it should be on the
minute you know you got your hint users
doing they're working type of all good
things don't you know next thing you
know boom everything goes down you know
what you do oh my god i can't work and
then you know if your IT person you know
the feeling they come to you with server
gonna be back up what can I do this
windy this is good on your nerve with
that stuff you're doing your best it's
trying to get them back up okay then you
have your redundant environment so your
dunno how to come back up with the
problem is how long does it take for
that we don't an environment to come
back up some of the things we talked
about previous previously to this you
know you have recovered and virtualized
systems but you just kicking can
continue to work with recover that
virtualized from application from the
appliance or the cloud now you have to
have an appliance that can do this by
the way if you don't have an appliance
that can spin up VMs
for you in a case of a disaster you need
to trash it because it's no good to you
it's just a waste of money then you want
your user to be able to keep working
then go back to that for a minute you
want your users via to keep working so
that appliance that I've talked about
needs to be something and again this is
a part of the IT service continuity
model um something that's going to meet
that model would be an appliance that
can spin up VMs maybe not all your
dreams but the most critical viens that
you need to keep going you need to
complete coverage you need to be able to
back up any device whether it be a
mobile desktop laptop support any
operating system doesn't matter which
one it is you want to maybe pull in any
form physical virtual you want to be
able to store in any cloud amazon google
microsoft azure and this company i'ma
tell you about here the second Empress
scale who I found to be very fascinating
they recently just made the Gartner cool
the company quaggan and they also have
made a visionary piece of it and I've
seen him in action and they're pretty
cool you want maybe recover anything
virtual machines application servers the
whole network you don't want to have
anything left out because you don't have
the capabilities to and you want to be
able to boot either from the cloud or
from that appliance you want to have big
to fail back any system it doesn't
matter which one it is let me tell you
real quick because I'm running out of
time here i want to give some time for
questions about this company that i
looked at they have what's called a push
button fell over so if you've never
heard of in infra still you may want to
go check them out and vet them you know
that and make sure that they fit your
company but what i like about em for
scale is that they they come right to
the IT service continuity management
model and with a push button film over
that supports all environments you can
do it anywhere in its wickedly fast i'm
talking about 15 minutes to bring up
your VMs and in a situation where that
is just incredible so you take that
downloads per hour down and you take it
in 15-minute increments and you can
report back to your financial folks that
we're going to lose this much money
versus two hours then
be in love with you you know they
recently made the like I said before if
you look here they are visionary and
you're climbing up so this is the
company look at you have all these
companies out out of here and the reason
why I don't like this company's come
here for two that's now a lot of people
who are nit have a hard time getting
spins approved from a financial people
come the equipment and the service is
just so expensive they offer total damn
protection and I love and one of the
other things i love because it aligns
with the IPL service continuity model is
their encryption model they have triple
triple encryption which is great
especially for a highly regulated
industries like banking and health care
the data is encrypted at the source
transfer build a secure connection and
then encrypt again in the cloud they
call it ultra-safe which is a pretty
cool technology so let me let me get on
here so I can get some questions there
but I am talking about ten ways to
immediately try to prevent ransomware
you know back up your data often trainer
users to exercise caution use revenue AV
software and firewalls now I recently
saw and read that of avg was being
acquired by a vast I believe but avg
claims that they have their AV that can
help fight against read somewhere you
may want to look at them as well to see
if that is the case for you but they're
a very good company I've worked with
them in a pass and I like working with
them so you may want to check them out
as well you want to separate your
witness for backup and obelisk analyzes
the case well when you when your backup
windows are backing up your data and
you're running your mouth where your
virus scans and things of that nature
the backup is going to copy the wrong
piece of data and you're going to miss
the opportunity to be able to get the
right data because the malware scanning
is running at the same time and leaving
those files unchanged or changed it just
depends so that's that's number four
something you might want to write down
and look at your backup windows right
now that if you're in charge of the
backups patch an update your software k
just stress and I I looked at two
systems to networks this week and three
of the and some of them are still using
windows 2003 and windows XP amazingly
but they're not going to be patched so
there no more patches to it you want to
show hidden file extensions so you can
see so you won't see the dot locking
extension on there you want to filter
your executables in the email you want
to disable files running from app data
and local app data folder on local
computers saw a situation where roaming
profiles can be a concern if your
profiles are on a different server you
need to make sure that that server is
adjusted properly disable our wee rup no
need our AP that's just an easy way to
get too big but it's also easy for rent
somewhere to screw you up you want to
enable pop up blockers so those two ways
to prevent I swear the next thing I'm
going to tell you about them i'm almost
done here it's five things to do if you
do get infected um of course you want to
remove infected machines from the
network traffic your bios time because
some of those things are time bomb roll
back from a previous backup which is
what I've been talking about all the
time stay current with the latest
threats which is hard to do especially
you're always fighting fires and things
of that nature and then of course you
want to alert the authority you have to
report it to OCR because now Rensselaer
is considered a breach so if you're in
health care industry you have to report
that if this breached you have to report
that breach to the office of civil
rights in the United States I don't know
about other countries but in the United
States definitely you have to report
that so that's my story and I'm sticking
to it I think the slide will be these
slides will be available to everyone on
I want to take time now to take any
questions from anyone in the audience or
from the UH presenter they call for
listening and how many questions now
right Manuel Oh looks like only has any
questions nothing is coming out or not
you would like to share anything before
we wrap up yes we can go ahead and if
not we can photo sessions well i think i
would like to say is that if you have an
IT person in your organization or even
if you don't taking a course to learn
these principles i know they like the
back of my hand but to learn these
parables simply learn is a great
resource for that i didn't get paid to
say that i'm just telling you they have
a very good ITIL program so it's worth
looking into at cellular com to go look
into what you can do to yeah I think you
might I don't know if you can take just
a single IT service continuity
management course I'd encourage you to
take the whole core to become certified
in it it's it's going to be a better
process for your IT moving along toward
the future with all of these cyber
attacks thank you so much manual and
let's let's stick around for some more
time if integrations comes in let let us
go ahead and answer that that'd be fine
fine um I know usually you guys have
something from simpler to offer I don't
know if you have anything you're
offering for this course and if you're
if you're going to send out the slide to
all the recipients or I need to do that
if they want anybody out there one copy
of the slides can you respond if you
want a copy of the slides well I don't
think there's a question on that okay
Jason needs a copy of that however we
have a question coming in from sub mill
who says uh after providing the ransom
money is there any chance to get the
full data um well just think about it
you're asking a bad guy to be a good
person you know so this person already
done something bad to you you can't
expect that they're going to do
something good for you just because you
pay them
tip the cases have been that you know I
Hollywood Presbyterian page seventeen
thousand dollars recently for ransom gay
supposedly they got their dead back my
concern would be I'm a former military
guy is that that did is toxic that that
is toxic because you got the resin back
but you don't know there's some other
time bomb in that ransom and that data
that these folks did to your data when
you when you bought a Bitcoin account
and you pay for so it's it's it's not
even a fifty-fifty chance I'd say it's
an 8020 change you get your data back
clean it without being corrupted you
know you'll probably get your data back
but you're not guaranteed to get your
data back and then when you do get your
data back you're not guaranteed that the
data is going to be uncorrupted I say
don't pay the ransom till you have
unpack up and disaster recovery plan
using the IT service continuity a model
it would be my answers don't use the
data even if i wouldn't pay the ransom
number one number two let's just say you
didn't have any choice because you
didn't have a good backup you know um
you still should not be comfortable with
that that data is clean that will be my
answer to you on that all right manuel
thank you so much for that and we have
the next question coming in from adrian
annotate the ransom incident should be
included in IPL program so your comments
on this week that the US where i should
be included IPO ITIL Service yeah I said
that earlier but I believe that um maybe
not read somewhere in particular but any
type of malabar but I what I said is I
think disaster recovery as a service
will become a part of the IPO service
continuity model because it's the best
way to fight ransomware it was a good
backup for instance that company I was
telling you about em for scale they've
helped organizations that I
known to be able to recover from a
disaster you know or have a good
disaster recovery plan i should say most
of them knowing them recovering from a
disaster because if you can push a
button and you can move on toward other
things and you know that the process is
in place and you have push button
disaster recovery and you use a hybrid
model of the cloud and a data center a
clown in the data center and your own
premise equipment through some kind of
an appliance you have a better chance of
getting your real data back then a rest
by gravity down it should be included
not ransomware itself because trust me
there'll be another x where that will be
out there you know malware virus that
will be out there coming soon the best
thing to know is that i can get my data
back without having to be bullied by
these rents where people oh that answers
your question I agree and I just here
Jenna agree to all right everyone oh we
still have 10 minutes of time so that we
you have any question you can you can
just I'll let many lil know because have
i'm seriously amazed with the answers is
giving its its own perfection answers to
to the point and we don't believe you
should be asking more questions in with
regards to article or any of the service
management queries because he's he's
been excellent so far thank you it was
this is a huge topic you know in it goes
across industry doesn't care what
history it is you know because the the
biggest industry is going to hit are
those right even the personal minister
like consumer industry right wedding
photos pictures of your baby videos of
your grandchildren there enough
somewhere attacks down on cell phones on
mobile phones and people are paying the
ransom you know and i don't really work
in a consumer industry but for business
you don't have to pay the ransom you
don't have to be afraid
if you have a good backup disaster
recovery system based upon these
principle from the IT service continuity
model you know when you look at some of
the things that are built into that you
really don't have to have anything to
fear you know the only thing you have to
fear is the education of your IT people
or the IT person working on your stuff
you know if you have somebody in the
nineteen department or multiple people
in your IT department or if you're that
one office manager that's doing it it is
so crucial to look at ITIL as your
management model for your IT you have
counting practice models you have
healthcare practice models you have CRM
practice models best practice models you
need an i.t i.t I you need an i-team
practice mother there's lingus cobit you
know there's Six Sigma you know home of
these things but I till to me it's the
most perfect because it specifically
talks about yeah and in times past uh
money has ruled the world there's even a
rap song that says cash rules everything
all around me now get the money dollar
dollar bill y'all well I wrote an
article recently that data rules
everything around me dream did you know
data rules all everything all right and
that's going to not just be something
that's happening now when you look down
the road big data data analytics
predictive analytics it's all about data
and if and if crooks can capture your
data they have everything out of your
money they have your peace of mind they
have everything from you and all you
have to do is just be able to have a
good backup and disaster recovery plan
based on models like IT service
continuity management model and your
solid you don't have anything to worry
about other than again the education
level of the people who are managing
your IT but if you get trained you get
certified if you get skilled you don't
have to worry about that either
alright thanks for that manual and we
have the next question coming in from
swapnam again the question reads apart
from the ITAR antivirus and the fire
road is there anything else like
software hardware which can be used to
protect from the ranch where attached so
do we have anything else which can
protect you yeah sure um if you go back
to see what slide was that for instance
now I only picked them because I'm not
really am impressed with this company
the height the infra scale company right
let me talk I mentioned to companies
that i know of it and then i'll use
those companies as an example but you
can choose whomever you like infra scale
for instance has an appliance a backup
appliance that you back up all the data
there and the data is dig Duke and
compress on that appliance then it only
sins like you know you do your initial
seed to the cloud then it only sends
changes right but that appliance in
itself is doesn't have an operating
system so it's not going to get infected
with ransomware and one of the other
things that can do is tell you about
weird changes that happen in your
environment that you need to take a look
at right so if you so you don't to be
back in a ransomware files obviously
right so that's one company the other
company that that I would say to you is
a company like course 360 course 360 is
a company in atlanta georgia and what
they do is they have a secondary site
right so it's a secondary site that
mirror is your site so that if you run
into a situation where you need to
failover you just fell over them and you
keep operating while you're cleaning up
your original site so there's really no
software out there that's going to help
you I mean ABG said they have a NMR
software that could help prevent
ransomware attacks you should take a
look at that okay um the other thing is
monitoring software if you don't have
remote monitoring and management
software to let you know when there's
some weird things going on to alert you
with an email
to alert you to do automated scripting
and think of that nature need to think
about that you know that's something we
do for our clients is we we do remote
monitoring and management and we manage
their network just make sure that
there's nothing going on weird on their
network and we monitored 24 hours a day
seven days a week anything that changes
servers routers firewalls whole nine
yard and then reports reports take a
look at your reports every week and look
at the reports look at the data look at
what's happening we're going to change
you know one of these seminars webinars
I can do could be unchanged management
you know I change management something
that's really really important and it
goes into the itl model again right so
the biggest thing is this really don't
software or hardware out there that can
help you other then if i pay having an
on-site appliance that deep due to
compressor sends those changes up to the
cloud and keep that data for you and
then those things can turn up your VMs
for you with your environment so that
the users can keep working so there's no
other software out there that I can tell
you about maybe you know a handy virus
firewall but even that we know what your
far along you are you using ssh srp are
using a failover model for your firewall
so if your firewall gets corrupted the
one can you fail over to another are
using load balancing and things of that
nature so so many things that go into it
but having a good plan preparation and
planning is where you start so you
prepare you plan your design you
implement you operate and you optimize
you going that cycle for prepared plan
design implement optimize I'm sorry
implement operate and optimize so those
are the best things I can tell you for
any kind of tools that you can use to
help you with ransomware all right
Manuel thank you so much and the next
question is coming from Ethel the state
show which ideal training program on
simply learn talks about the continuity
management so i can take that up yes I
told it will be the CSI continual
service improvement which is under the
ITIL intermediate so you can get in
touch with
because support team who will provide
you the detail information on that i'll
be more than happy to provide you
anything else if you have correct me if
i'm wrong manual it's CSI right
continuous a simple hard yes yes oh
you're absolutely right okay any other
question please well we still have three
minutes and we are making the most of it
manual has been a very kind enough to
answer all the questions in detail like
I said it's been fantastic you have any
any any question let's a word and bring
it on the chat window so that I can take
it up with the manual my level best to
answer at
okay Manuel will give one minute and
we'll wait for the next question okay
all right Manuel thank you so much for
your time and I do not see any questions
like I stated it was a fantastic session
thank you so much for sharing all your
experience or expertise on ITIL
especially on the canoe continuity model
so let's go ahead and wrap up the
session for today and once again
everyone thank you so much for joining
and it was fantastic to have manual on
the session thank you well okay all
right once again thank you so much and
have a very good day ahead take care bye
you